build yeah okay for people who are
joined in livestream we are talking
about audio functionality for upcoming
version woven language I am subdued
today because I have a cold
um so alright let's get going here so
what should I be looking at here so well
so first of all the audio GUI there's
been a lot of you know quality
improvements simplifications it's now
works in cloud oh it does
existing cloud it should yeah and the
nice thing is that it's the same code of
essential you know branching it's so if
I say here um hello hello hello but I'm
not totally wild about the that gray
stop button I don't really understand
that gray stop button why is it gray in
the audio capture you mean yes why is it
great why isn't it black I mean it's not
grayed out it should be you know it is
the thing you press next right yeah I
let me check okay seems wrong to me
they set the zoom hold on a second I'm
going to try to set this to how do I do
share I think I think you should set the
the default dollar default audio output
device yeah
can you you couldn't hear any of that I
couldn't hear okay ready set then you
probably need to share the audio as well
when you share something there's a buck
oh yeah I just I just checked that
button for zoom yeah in zoom I just
checked that button
no it's when you start the new surely
you will not find it I know I know I
know I know I just did that when they
started you sure I stopped the share I
pressed the button that says well it in
the share it says share computer sound
I checked it okay maybe you can tell
you're recording and okay because maybe
that is what the heck is that
again the auto type did there are still
there is some work on devices in
prototype that okay so can I record or
not oh yeah yeah I should not be a
problem hello and recording now look
that shouldn't be gray okay just
shouldn't be gray
I mean it's wrong that to be gray okay
we're not hearing anything you hearing
anything
are you actually recording can you do an
audio plot of that but it seemed to it
seemed to have some signal inside it the
input device will tell us what the
situation is I don't know what that is
yeah so maybe you just want the computer
microphone or something and I said that
[Music]
display
maybe we might try the zoom audio device
as well here that might pick up your
microphone hopefully okay but but why
there to display audio things here and
how would it distinguish between them
there's a good question I'm not sure
what happens with devices that have the
same reported name they are different
but if you input display audio I don't
know which one would be chosen
hello I'm now trying to record again by
the way it doesn't encourage me that
there's no yep that is not a good sign
it probably will not have worked
that is very obnoxious dad okay all
right let me let me go and look in the
cloud here um yeah you might just want
to do an audio generator of white noise
just to check that that works because
audio capture I'm not sure if there's
enable or not in the class why doesn't
this also complete good question
we'll have to check with audio
autocomplete people there are a lot of
usages in audio generator that's
probably why the auto autocomplete needs
to be it needs to be fit on the fixed
yeah yeah okay okay um okay
so now in the production cloud you're
saying well if I go here and open new
notebook okay I say audio capture no it
didn't work so what's the story here
audio capture it's not yet supported on
the cloud but if you do all your
generator for example data of any audio
that report
pretty slow what's it doing okay that
doesn't strike me as working that was
not good right okay okay so that was bad
you saw what it did right the red ring
was super slow rendering my connection
temporally well it just it didn't render
properly okay so it was very slow to
render but you're gonna make audio
capture work right yeah okay you have
just to figure out exactly how do I mean
we can connect to
I think Java to the output devices so
I'm sure we'll be able to do the same to
the input devices why is this so slow
look rendering is slow - hello I am a
computer good ah we crashed see that
what crashed okay we all have to test
the cloud more often but it should be on
the test suite for the cloud so they
should already be finding that this
crashed that time it didn't
but the border at the bottom is broken I
don't know why it crashed that time but
it did okay so something to look at
right yep
also you got to figure out what to do
with the two identical display devices
we are in the process of switching to a
different back-end for playback and
device management okay so hopefully I
mean there is an obvious solution just
to append an integer to the devices that
have the same name that that will solve
the problem immediately but yes we had
not okay consider now um yet now we're
going to do speech synthesized of my
thing here and now what am I saying here
I'm saying speech speak style I don't
like that no no no no no it's not that
speak style speak style is kind of like
style so that's like we'll dig into that
shortly but first of all let's use a
higher quality of speech synthesizer and
that's currently I believe method okay
but but so what does that okay was what
do I say here there's no other complete
no no this is just hooked up in like
yesterday do you have to this is this
proof today's prototype I don't know
looks like it's yesterday's okay so
maybe if you say method goes to IBM
Watson for instance oh one word yep it
will probably take you through
authentication though we are being
unpleasant experience for now exactly
yeah okay hopeless and please when it
when it errors out we get it to not
produce garbage like that
if you want to listen to it so one thing
is that this is one to two generations
ahead of the speech synthesizer to
generic speech synthesizer that we have
that ships with the binary okay so I
mean if Carla shared it or someone else
that has doesn't matter I've heard these
things that better yes you know there
any that we can build in or are they all
external api's which require they're all
the IP is do they require independent
API keys for our all of our users yes
okay so we need to talk to partnerships
and see whether any of them we can make
some deal with okay there is the again
this is still future of development
there are some nuts that do synthesis
but the import of those two [ __ ] is
working on a part of one of these nuts
there wavenet vocoder but yeah I will
have higher quality it will have also
much much higher computational
requirements yeah well its life yeah
exactly
it is it is in the future it's not
something that we can have right now
okay I don't really care about these
things they're external services that
require separate keys I don't think
anybody's ever gonna use them
I mean it's amusing but I don't think
it's really useful I mean the one option
is to have something with the service
credits potentially if we I know that
requires a deal right that requires a
deal mm-hm yeah okay but but these
things where you can just go there and
you get your own key I just don't care I
mean you could just do that the proper
way to manage it is to not have to do it
each session if you don't want to use it
you do it once and then that gets stored
as you're good I know but but but but
then you're still you've got an account
and you got a subscription just an
outside service and it's a big
complicated mess
sure I just don't think anybody's gonna
use it yeah Roger they care and
authentication with what Stephen had pop
up it's gonna save their credentials but
setting up all of those accounts --is
yeah it's incredibly non-trivial and
it's not clear it's probably not free
and it's probably you know you're paying
three different vendors and it's a big
mess it's kind of not what we're going
well someone start free but yeah doesn't
matter I mean it's it's some I just
don't think it's useful I think it's not
a good I mean other than to know what's
possible I don't think it's very useful
okay
in any case okay what is speak style so
you go to that page in in the ref guide
in the actual rough guide or a doc you
toss in CVS yeah industrials your
answers so what this
do um I think one of the big thing
there's config called prosody it tells
you how you pronounce things I
understand well while he's capitalized
so what we did is to do instead of doing
well they could be first of all yeah
they need to be no no a day they
probably should be second but you see
that there's one speak style that it's a
there's a lot of things that you can
style with this one as opposed to having
a symbol that says emphasis another
symbol that says bright I think it's a
good idea but I think the way it needs
to work is some Association I mean I
don't think it I think it should be
speaking style probably okay um and you
know it's a string followed by and then
presumably it's a style which could be
specified as you know emphasis goes to
seven or something and I think this is
their current implementation but so it
works okay except capitalization of
curves the big mess is that this maps to
the SS ml which is some XML format for
speech synthesis the problem is that
every service has its own twist in it so
so let's let's get some very basic
things obviously export SS ml should
work so the one thing that is curious is
you you don't see xs/s m/l files you see
as a small strength is the most common
sports train yeah yeah yeah absolutely
we are able to convert between one and
the other routines speak style and and
XML okay but fine but then those are
export formats OSS ml will show up as an
export format right and an import format
yep and then the import format it will
return a symbolic speaking style thing
that correct I think that's the plan
okay so what if I want to put together a
so if I say speech synthesized so if I
say speech synthesized and then I say
here a table I squared I to Phi
something whoops so I'm assuming that
this will say the list 1 4 9 16 25 okay
so it's saying the list yeah this is
based on spoken string at the moment no
no I understand that but how would I get
a series of things where I say 1 2
highly emphasized right how do I do that
how do I get something which has
different pieces of speaking style for
different parts of the thing so if you
look at the second usage in the box of
speak style you can see that this can be
nested the first argument of speaks are
could be a list so you could have either
list of string and then speak style with
a different emphasis for example I'm not
sure I'm keen on that so the point is
you need to be able to nest this kind of
expression because as I said you might
need right the question is whether the
speech synthesized if given a list just
concatenate the things together if the
speak style head I would say yeah no no
no no without the speaking style head
because what you would want to have
there is the following thing you want to
say speak speech synthesized of hello
you know speaking style yeah I see what
I mean and that one and I would argue
that there are some single word things
emphasized or something that you should
support here sure that doesn't seem
unreasonable and actually we might have
discussed that already so the issue with
this is how do you distinguish between
these two behaviors right because you
might just want to say the list whatever
in some cases but in the second case you
said you just want to say hello and then
join the various so that having a
speaking style had at the beginning but
if I know but that sighs it's a
it's a hack and it's not a good idea the
list a comma B comma C that's horrifying
did you hear what that said yep
that's truly horrifying so they should
be able to have it say the list I think
that there could be a way of doing this
okay look we could reuse something like
verbatim okay leave that very corner
case because I don't think anybody's
gonna care about that case I'm sure sure
yeah I agree that no one's gonna care
about that case and the one issue that I
can potentially see right now is if you
want to nest
you have speaking style you if you had
two words then you still want to be able
to have a list of two things so you
absolutely
so they both synthesize on speaking
style can take a list as that first or
yeah so speaking of thought already that
is I understand that but I'm saying
speech synthesizers I think at the top
level should be able to do that okay
that that's fine if we decided that's
the default behavior that seems nice you
should try and support like verbatim as
the way to yeah get the old behavior
it's a little weird
I think we can reuse it here um it's a
little weird but it is a very good use
of it in this case okay voice style beta
what is that the thing that tells you
which kind of voices you can use for
speech synthesis okay went through this
before there is not there's nothing new
there except that when we are hooking up
to external services now you can get
voices for those services as well ok so
if I say this for example if I if I do
this one Fiona so you're saying that I
can speech synthesized Fiona here
correct okay so what will I say here I
would say you can just say Fiona if you
want or you can use the full
specification the list 1 4 9 16 25
I think she's Scottish mildly Scottish
now if it's the wrong language here it
will just speak in a weird accent the
least subtle empath symbol on an
umbrellas do a pool of Lima that was a
strange accent that was a translation
yep because those have numerals other
than and actual strength if you hold one
two three that would just be that would
be no there is no translation is what
I'm saying because the numerals that are
because they were recorded it's not what
you're saying the point is they speak
style a spoken string transformed that
list into a string with numbers inside
like the list world the world roots
quote the world sleeps hot the world the
world Joel bleep world
the world internal or to talk world you
have a list of world so you make you
might want to string join those that may
be what is happening in this one oh I
got a riffle
I'm going to do yeah so um let's just
say
also goodness sake not ideal I would say
all these characters when do we get to
have them um where do we get to have
phonetic alphabet so this is kind of
what the speak style also supports some
is a country in Southeast Asia between
the Indian and Pacific Oceans it is the
world's largest island country weaved
more than is a country in Southeast Asia
between Indian and Pacific okay okay
it's quite jolly there is no translation
as you have it's just no I understand
that
yeah I understand okay okay okay so now
if I take this and I say speech
recognizer and now I can't see what
happens here what is it by the way this
is still not a correctly standardised
box this is what we are working on well
Julia mainly is working on standardizing
as much as possible all these two boxes
the problem is that we don't really have
a standard at this point right that
train does one thing classify does
another thing you know I know I know but
we are working yes Julia is that was
very respectable what speech recognizer
did for that by the way it's not
surprising anything yeah okay one speech
recognizer okay let's go on to speech
interpreter that if we can do that yeah
and if it's let's see if it isn't a
prototype or not it should be if it is
not I can share if you'd prefer that
well here let's so what I've got to do
is that
say speech synthesized Indonesia and
then I've got to say speech interpreter
of country of that yeah Dada
yeah another angle there is nothing
particularly convoluted it's just
recognizing what transcribing their
their speech and then essentially
passing to interpret their okay but now
if what I did here was um you know let's
say I did this okay that's pretty fine I
understand so it's really doing two
steps here yes it is nothing it's
nothing particularly new but it is a
convenient shortcut that I would say
okay and those futurist usages those
should already work not all interpretive
categories are sensible why on earth did
you have semantic expression things that
I don't think you want that yes no
actually that is exactly what we want
because for example if you say one it
will not be transcribed as a number of
digit it will be transcribed as oh and
II so you always seem to want to prefer
the semantic number semantics expression
I agree is probably not used form a
semantic number is well semantics
expression might be let me try doing
this I mean if I say um speech
synthesized of of let's say if I say x
squared plus y squared there it will use
the speak mechanism right correct
Wow
I am still blown away they did something
sensible what you all you might want to
check is what the output of speech
recognizer data is let's see what it was
understood yeah something like this I do
not expect speech recognizer to perform
well because the language model well why
did it miss the X there's a good
question this is definitely not what the
language model is expecting it has never
been exposed to this kind of speech okay
okay what you could do maybe which is
ugly no you're probably never mind okay
well I think this function is very nice
I mean I think it's some yeah so one
thing that I think is a place that this
might turn out to be interesting is
places like forum functions I agree
completely I was about to say that
so these this is there the big I think I
know where this shortcut as well is
useful yeah I mean so to me
I was always thinking that we would have
just like we have form function that we
would have some kind of voice function
oh okay where are you in yeah well we're
on the phone for example the thing is
just you know it's like a Serie button
or something but I don't know how it
works if you have um I mean by the time
you have multiple fields it's a bit
clunky to have to press the microphone
button on each field right because
that's what you know what what is the UX
that you're imagining here I mean to my
mind the better UX would be a series of
form pages in which it's saying say the
color now you say it I say Edie you know
don't use one way only if you have
one page where you have to reach
question [ __ ]
thing you have a button that while it is
pressed you have a curving but this is
how the exhaust from one point to
another
yeah I think it's much better to go
through where where what you basically
have look if you have a forum this is
something we need to talk to I guess
Ricardo and Carlo about what we'll need
is a form that has speech interpreter as
the interpreter yeah it's so so right
now form can take interpreter arrow
something or another and this is now a
speech interpreter but it needs some
separate UI because the typical thing
will be multi-page forms where you know
it says it just says say the color now
yeah yes some kind of automated call
thing yeah that seems actually only some
okay so so another possibility is the
pure voice motion where it's saying say
the color now and then let's you say
that if we can do that on the phone side
say the color now you say it say the you
know the amount now or something
don't saying yeah and all we say can be
user customized doing things provided
yes I mean that that would be a you know
a voice function exactly where the thing
is initiated once you say go right as a
voice as something with voice yeah
there's the other option that I see
being practical as this kind of mixed
interface you know I think the biggest
advice is interesting too but but both
of these require you okay can you get
with parth to talk about the UX for the
apps because that's there's going to be
a necessary piece to this so one
question on that are we what parts of
death are we planning to provide
prepackaged and rather than just
providing the ingredients and the user
letting letting the user build more on
this
um um so I'll do just envisioning maybe
just a minute
yes sir
not just a second
sorry
keep keep talking um yeah my question
was what part of this voice foil do we
want to provide the user we want to
provide the full package of the one just
to provide parts for the of it
what d'Alene I think we want to provide
something which makes it easy to do okay
so do it voice firm and then a bunch of
fields and then everything will be will
happen out to mocking voice function
I think this transition I mean we
designed this like three years ago or
something um although I think that this
version is you know so it's voice
function and you basically have a prompt
and then you have an interpreter from
that prompt yeah and then what we need
is is in the I didn't understand that
you know so so the whole thing is a
voice interaction I see
somewhat of a almost a conversational
agent but like very limited
[ __ ] to us the interpretation
well I mean the fact is we should be
able to do a conversational agent and we
should figure out how that works through
these functions and you are envisioning
this this interaction happening both in
a notebook and on a website for example
I think more of a phone okay I mean I
suppose also on web site mean it needs
some UX design yeah because I I don't I
I have my think okay this is I know
that's why I told you to talk to earth
who knows about that stuff
who can connect you to the people who do
know about that stuff that's going to
the people um I think the notebook case
is amusing but not all that important
seems reasonable um we may as well want
to have validation step for voice I
don't know a form function API function
I have that a production probably not
something like did you mean Italy yes
some yes I understand
yeah that that didn't
that doesn't happen you're right but
that isn't a thing a form function
actually doesn't have that that's an
interesting point I mean it does when
there are multiple interpretations that
can do that you know what I'm saying so
it has a UI for checking the
interpretation but you're right this
this one I mean this needs some design
and seems to me there are three cases
here one is the multi the form with many
entries some of which are voice enabled
or even all of which are voice enabled
so that if you press the microphone
button you can speak to it that's case
one case two is the conversational
assistant thing that uses that is
essentially a loop probably using ask to
go around doing different things with
voice and the third case is probably the
voice based form-filling making sense
which is more the voice you know maybe
it's really cool voice form function
where it's just like you're describing
things where it's a fixed I don't know
what the interaction between that and
ask should be but there's probably a
simple case where you're just filling in
three parameters or something and it's
just asking you you know please tell me
this please tell me this please tell me
this you fill those in and then it goes
and goes to the payload and takes
whatever action it needs to take no I
would think people
boys form functional voice function some
questions around a live stream a great
example that for 12.1 net training and
nach to decompose a single audio channel
into multiple voices there is an
interesting application there are
several papers that present something
like that and one of these papers uses a
unit to do that
which is something we can definitely
have in our system and train easily
another system but we haven't but it is
something that we and I said it is
something that is present in literature
and is something that we can do with our
system as I said looking at units is my
suggestion for something ok I'll try a
net for wave 2 midi transcoding so we
already have a limited version of that
if you go to pitch recognize that is
essentially what it does yeah all right
but doing it for the full rim there is a
non solved problem there are some very
good papers that do polyphonic
transcription of piano music but it's
limited to classical music played on
piano so ok one very small subset right
fair enough
so anyone ever integrated Mathematica
into automated phone service I think the
answer is no I wonder whether there's an
interesting use case for that um you
know back in the day you might remember
math source maybe none of you remember
math source from before the web 1989
when we were first trying to get people
to download things there was a phone
based way of doing that with touch tones
and so on very bizarre right it's it's a
premium yeah I mean that the whole thing
about DTMF sand you know recognizing
touch tones I don't think we have that
do we do we have touched on recognizer
you know no we don't I don't know that
it's worth having it I would say
because they're something that is
difficult to build with just computing
spectrums no I understand but if it's an
easy I think it's a good thing for the
function repository at least to have a
little okay that is the David David
agree yeah I don't think it's worth
having a system but I just said function
functions that seems like and yeah i
mean i don't think i mean it's it's
funny how the world has changed in the
last thirty years because you know that
was a big deal back in the day but not
anymore
i think we do have some examples of that
in their example notice when we packages
so it's a DTMF recognized or something
or touchstone recognized um so we can
just give it a sequence of touch tones
and it will recognize and i think there
will be useful okay okay mohamed on
livestream mentions a dhobi project loco
is worked on neuron that but synthesizes
speech from a voice it will be nice to
have but the synthesizer speech from a
voice you mean you mean a style transfer
or no noise yeah and there are some
things that so remember how i was
mentioning that to cheetah is working on
a part of importing and not to do speech
synthesis now the nice thing is that
this speech synthesis that is separated
it has several components one is the
vocoder one is the generator for the
male spectrums and this generator for
the mouth vector guns can be conditioned
which will determine how the resulting
voice will sound okay so if everything
goes well that might help us in diagram
that'd be cool so in other words you
would learn from one voice what the
conditioning of the mel spectrograms
should be and then you could translate
one voice into another one
that way it would not be a complete
translation that would be as kind of a
lie every ble synthesis you would first
recognize which verse words were spoken
and i new vid synthesized
conditioning on some other voice that
you want to use as target okay but I
mean then then what you're saying is
that in addition to these voices here
right you're saying that you could have
a custom voice I think this net would
allow that yes okay so then what you're
saying is that speech synthesis speech
synthesized its second argument could be
some kind of example data or something
well no I'm not thinking yeah I mean
right what would it look like
structurally what would be it will be
some kind of voice I the voice style
function or something I would say you
could even just dump all your data into
it right just make it sound like death
now I understand that but you don't want
to do that every time you want to have a
voice say I'll function it comes out of
that so you want to basically train it
to generate a voice style function yeah
so there the conditioning from what I
know about this network is just a vector
right you give it some audio data this
will produce a vector that will be fed
as one of the inputs to the synthesis so
the information about the voice is
compressed into red so what I'm saying
is it's like a feature extract exactly
right so I mean in a sense to get the I
mean you just need something which is
pre set up to feed into speech
synthesized and that might be a voice
style function or it might be some
feature extractor voice tau object oh
yeah probably a voice style object this
is in the future we are only working on
the import of one part of this project
so this will seem take okay
all right let's try the next one speech
cases so what you're saying there it's
okay so if I say speech cases of now if
I if I do this this is going to be a you
have the next cell with the speech
synthesizers might be a good input for
that you know I know I know I know I'm
just gonna give it a bit longer okay
stuff yeah that might take a bit more
time to recognize but yeah so let's be
let's be kind and not give it the poor
in the vision woman um why did that go
so quickly
Oh a synthesis is very fast that polymer
is our cognition okay percent 57 man so
well now what we're gonna say is speech
cases percent 57 and then we will say
here something like quantity yeah we'll
see what happens but that should work
out and they said recognition is always
heavy without a Tribune what is
finalized
does that relevant language model
correct and now what's happening now
it's doing text cases or something yes
correct
maybe one quantity goes to
interpretation
I do oh but there will it I don't think
I'm not sure how much caching is
happening maybe that is something that
we want to improve on I don't know how
much cash you really I mean to - one
thing again doesn't seem I mean I think
what's gonna be bad here is that that's
gonna be incompatibility between the
progress monitors but that's a minor
issue I mean we have the the framework
in place to do some caching speech
recognizer but I decided it doesn't seem
that purposeful that's pretty damn
impressive
if you ask me they collect well looks
correct accurate yeah especially if you
consider this is just a bunch of neural
networks Stockton to each other I think
that's rather low human guidance except
for the training this is pretty good
very nice cool okay why can't they
recognize that it is speech before
deciding how to do it we don't really
have any good way of recognizing
something is so why don't we just build
a classifier that recognizes speech i
but it's really easy but the point is
you could use this method for other
things that have not speech to get
different effects I'm sure but I still
think that by default we should
recognize whether the thing is speech
okay I mean we could like it'll do
identify application it is the problem
is that you have to on some kind of
neural network before I understand but
I'm saying let's have it be some really
lightweight thing because I I predict
that speech or not speech it's gonna be
very easy we have enough data to verify
this assumption I think there's a
reasonable assumption okay so I mean we
could use the audio identify yup dataset
or something
make a very very very cheap classic
there was there was my idea right it
sounds sensible to me and then method
are automatic and decide what to do okay
and we'll measure the performance and
see if it is fine but I think you can
get it done in milliseconds okay okay
audio instance cue oh well audio
identifies such a cruddy function right
now yeah the nice thing about audio
instance cue is that it is given that
the output of all identify is more vague
in the sense that there's multi-label
this cue test is a bit more gentle than
just doing audio identifying or
something yeah maybe I mean is it a balk
is it uh is it a croak isn't that is
something that I solved is it a bar
cause a croak that might be a bit less
reliable yeah um okay well I mean I'm
not I I don't you know this is what it
is you identify it's not that impressive
there is nothing special about that it's
just yes we do have you need to go to
all your extreme new is anybody know why
we're why these things are out default
the opening with dynamics every time now
anyway okay so if a page has an audio
object in and out acquire something I
mean I see okay so what's all of this
this is a framework to play
programmatically things right so you you
can start from an audio object a list of
all the objects or a function to play
things and from a device you will be
able to occur things
and the things that we are adding what's
the difference in audio capture an audio
record it is not blocking audio record
is not blocking you can say all your a
coil of something and it will go on in
the background till you tell it to stop
and you can execute any kind of
computation in the meantime I say okay I
mean within reasons of course there is a
callback and if you have a super-huge
blocking computation another so audio
record when you when you say will you
stop it then returns so it returns a
stream and then you can access the
record that audio either buy a property
or however you want to call it of the
stream or just saying audio of that
stream that has stopped recording okay
so this is basically I leave this on
it's recording you know all kinds of
random background stuff um and then so
if I left this on you know recording all
my random you know meetings or something
yeah would it would it croak quickly or
would it could it record 10 hours of
stuff I mean if stuff and it will by
default it will dump all that data
online on a file so will not kill you of
memory okay except if of course if the
file gets that big but okay I've not
right but it's recording it like 4000
kilohertz or something by default yeah
yeah okay cool I'll have to try that
okay audio plot so this one there is
much to be discussed at this point okay
speed
periodicity what on earth does that mean
so this these are interesting things
that are very specific as you have
noticed so these all of these well the
first three of those properties and come
from a vocoder
which essentially takes a signal
decomposes it into more simple almost
symbolic quantities for example pitch
after velocity in spectral envelope and
then you can if you want you can modify
this components and really synthesize a
different speech signal and this is a
nice and convenient way to get this
information if you want to a periodicity
gives you information on transients
fundamental frequency this is another
way that we can do pitch recognize
essentially that is optimized for speech
I would say the performance of this is
very good on speech but I mean there
isn't a fixed pitch in speech no this is
a title I'm serious yeah okay and the
spectral envelope is also some kind of
measure that is interesting especially
in speech signals this is a laid to do
the formants of the speech signal oh
yeah yeah go ahead we have a number of
comments on our live stream from Bob who
says well I really like to make as a
purely synthetic voice for use in
animations or have a speech over for
videos that is different to every other
voice okay hmm there are several
alternatives this vocoder thing is one
one the classic I said a classic signal
processing route well that's an your
various mell weightings that should
allow you to have a unique voice yes by
randomly picking yes by unduly picking
well not randomly that by weighing
differently their spectral envelope is
essentially what what creates
characteristics
if you want to instead do again with
their knife you need the power we can
imagine we can imagine a function
repository function that creates a
random voice well well there won't be
barriers they won't be as rich as if you
wanted for animation you want them to
have very rich characteristics this
vocoder have very limited variability
it's not that interesting I just got
okay I think we need some some some kind
of Richard you know Richard technologies
right okay another question here can you
stream audio from the web like BBC Radio
and convert it to text in real time we
do have some mechanism don't we for
getting streamed audio yes we sorry we
don't get a really stream Laurie we can
get audio that is on a file on the
internet and we can stream it in but a
live stream currently the only method
that you could do to get it in real time
would be connected to it as a device
essentially directing the audio from a
browser to advise and then to the device
to Mathematica and you can do this with
virtual device but it's not practical so
wait a minute so you go to a live stream
yep and I think the goal for us is to be
able to have streams in audio as well
that's not necessarily connected to a
file yeah is it possible to have them
streaming from the web or is that I
don't even know how that works I mean it
isn't that using the UM what is it
called they'd be um oh gosh what does
that protocol are STP what is it I think
that one of Em's called are STP okay but
but I mean I don't know how you connect
to that I mean so is there essentially a
URL that is the stream
I do not know about this we and I just
sending one thing we did now which is
one thing that we already shipped which
is this first iteration you could
connect sort of to a URL it would then
proceed to download it to a file and
then start playing it for you anymore
but it's it's so it can start playing
before it's attached the whole thing
downloads so I think what Stephen is
saying is different what you're saying
is like there is a file on the internet
and we can stream the file I think what
he's saying is like some live podcasting
yeah that's what I'm saying that I don't
know nothing about I don't I don't know
yeah yeah um okay continuing here
notable person that's cool speaker
gender hopefully we don't get ourselves
in trouble with that anyway um well yeah
unfortunately we only have two genders
in our thoughts set but yeah well that's
this is the apparent gender based on
speech which is all that one can get
from speech based on speech and the data
center we have used I guess the
limitations of result um okay speaker
descriptor what is that for
so we already have some features some
audio features that you are computer
automatically which is the real powerful
news case I've already identified test
answers yeah and here is the same thing
but stemming from an app that was trying
to classify speakers so these features
will have semantic information on what
kind of voice is in the recording I
understand which you could potentially
feed back into speech synthesized to get
that voice again good as I said that is
a whole future of development but yes
that is the the idea that we get some
semantic information about voice so
where are we at with dilation I so as I
said the currents
so the project is I we have it net
trained for speaker classification we
have the same net being fine-tuned to
optimize this embedding for voices and
now the output of this fine tune that is
what I am trying to use first speaker by
realization I am getting so the issue is
that I don't have a good way of
evaluating the performance of this I
only have qualitative examples at the
moment I am just using so I'm just
thinking about where you could get
something well a couple of papers that I
found just two days no but do you need
something where you have voices and
where you know where the markers are
between the voices yeah but there is
also something that is not difficult to
construct at least to get an idea but I
what I'm looking for is a reliable
metric to measure the performance of
their relation which is less trivial
then I mean one way to do it obviously
with the just the voices is just take
random pieces of speech just gather and
we do have the data to do that and this
is what I am doing now but as I said I
am missing a good metric to evaluate the
results why isn't it just I mean you
know you know where the markers are
between these speeches speak speakers
you just say what fraction of overlap do
you have that's correct and you give
yourself a weight of you know plus 1 or
something whenever they agree and minus
1 when they don't agree and you just
take the integral of that that is the
problem is if you have two speakers that
if for example the realization
[Music]
recognizes the first bit of one speaker
as speaker - but then switches to the
correct speaker I don't know there is
some subtle tone of fun these effects
that I am investigating so you want to
you need to make a loss function out of
these or what no I want to evaluate if
the net that I current we have that I am
planning to use is actually valid okay
it gets me good I think you should get
anecdotal information before you dive in
I do III I already have it seems okay
if you know the number of speakers that
seems to give consistent consistent
consistent decent results if you leave
automatic detection of the number of
speakers that is a bit more racy I say
okay well that's that's not totally
terrible so it was on our list Stephen
we just for the risk managing the risk
for this release we put it in 12 - yeah
but it is something that because all of
these projects are voice related they
are all connected to each other it's a
piece of another project so okay speaker
match cue it seems to me like with faces
like what you really want is here's a
bag of faces which one is this
particular face that seems like that's
the most common you know real question
isn't it
I mean what are we doing for facial
recognized shoddy do you know what what
do you mean we don't have it yet but we
said given the set of faces for people 1
2 3
which one is the new image right so I
mean I would have thought the right way
to do that is you can either have an
association or a list of rules of the
form picture of face arrow you know name
or something or list of pictures of the
face our name I mean you could argue
that this is nearest write a feature
nearest feature so what are you I'm
doing for that is I am analyzing one
data set I am analyzing the distribution
of distances between same and different
speakers and I think I'm getting
somewhere sensible okay but then but I'm
still saying I think what is it gonna be
called face recognized or something for
the other one yeah okay you can you can
open the page that is in the CVS if you
want to see the design we said oh well
fine very sensible I don't understand
what method are recognizers doing but
let's see why we haven't touched it this
is but then I think second example is
gonna have or or there is going to be an
example with more than one instance
there versa yeah I hadn't really thought
of that I mean I was thinking of
individual faces but yes that's case
obviously doubtful I've gotta go
fortunately but you guys continue okay
um yeah I think we're basically done
here so what's happening to face very
nice is that um is that making it soon
or is this for a while for now what we
are wrapping up is better face detection
as well as face alignment which is going
to be useful as well for face
recognition yeah I mean surprisingly
good right now yep okay if it can be
even better great but it seems like
these um you know look that the thing
here okay the test case is this okay
given an employee directory of hours can
we take one of these you know pictures
of the company and recognize all the
people in it think that's a good test
case okay all right well very good
nothing else when are we going to get to
doing music theory stuff I think that's
more important than you guys I mean I
think it is not so difficult and I think
we should get to it I disagree with the
first part I agree completely with the
second one but yeah I think after this
all speaker elated stuff I think that is
what we have gone in for I am very
excited about it so I agree that I
alright okay I would be excited to do it
fair enough but I mean the stuff
involved NOFA isn't terrible
yeah but it's not extendable that is the
big issue and what sense
so you really want to build a framework
where you can express complex things
like squirrels that is the goal that the
current building blocks do not extend
very well they say what we have is
things like scales but what you want to
do is you have a complete score we want
it like speak star we won't speak star
for music right that is the goal we want
to be able to express the symbolic
representation of the music piece
complete us yes so that is the issue it
what if that those will be useful
building blocks at the beginning I'm not
saying we will throw those away
definitely it would be nice to just
implement those things because those
will be useful in their own right yeah
for lots of educational applications
particularly obviously even if you don't
yet get the bigger framework having
those things if we know how what the
design is gonna be I strongly encourage
just taking those things yeah so we had
some discussion about the design things
have not 100% clear on what the design
is gonna be so what sir go ahead honey
no I was gonna say we really do then
continue on that project your discussion
either being distracted or focused I
think you should just take an hour or
two and try and see whether you can hash
out a basic design because if you can
and we can just move over the stuff we
have in Wolfram Alpha that will be a
very good start so we try to do that and
we couldn't okay well it involve me if
you want I mean I'm happy to yeah talk
about that yeah all right good stuff
anything else
excellent okay nice stuff all right
thanks hey bright focus on Ice Cube bye